recording alright let's get into
audience questions for the week three
very timely and prescient questions I
think I would say the first one is hey
David are you addicted to your
smartphone
why are smartphone so addicting and how
do you deal with it
we're actually scheduled to have a
really good interview about technology
addiction and digital healthy digital
lifestyles or maybe that's not the best
way to say it but I think you'll you'll
know it when you hear it next week
I don't I don't think I'm addicted to my
smartphone but I am very conscious of
times where my smartphone use has sort
of gotten to a place where I'm not super
comfortable with it that the reason that
smartphones are so addicting is by
design there's basically two elements to
why it's so rewarding not in like an
emotional sense but like to the brain to
keep scrolling through social media and
it basically comes down to two factors
and Cal Newport has written about this
and so of many psychologists and others
I've just recently read Cal's material
on this one is that social media is sort
of and and our smartphones are designed
with a variable reward system and when
you go back to these old animal tests I
don't remember if it was rats or Birds
or whoever but what what scientists
determined was when you set up a system
that rewarded animals with food on a
variable basis where you might press a
button and get no food or get one pellet
or six pallets and it was unpredictable
the animals became way more fixated on
pressing the button than if it was just
when you press it you get half a pellet
and that's it that's how social media
and email and all of that stuff works
the entire notification paradigm did I
do I have anything in there it's like
pulling a slot machine and you might
have like some notifications or you
might have new emails but the emails
might be spam or they might be really
good if you have an online business they
might be messages about a new order that
came in for example or whatever the case
may be
the variable reward
a situation paradigm is one reason why
people keep scrolling and then the other
is that a lot of those variable rewards
relate to social approval so when it
comes to likes Facebook messages
notifications comments on stuff you
posted app messages on Twitter not only
is there the variable reward system but
it's not just did I hit the slot machine
and get some money
it's notifications or rewards that sort
of validate your self-worth on the basis
of how are other people reacting so
that's like the core of why these
devices are so addicting and it's by
design I mean there are whistleblowers
from the tech world who have said this
is exactly how these things were
designed speaking candidly during design
meetings that this is exactly what what
we were trying to do so the way I try to
deal with it is I try to have just very
very particular habits with a lot of
this stuff I've not done the thing where
I uninstall a bunch of apps from my
phone or put software on my computer
that doesn't let me go to social media
websites I've basically because social
media stuff is related to my job because
we do use these platforms for promoting
the show I've established in my workday
a period in the morning and a period in
the afternoon where I will go through
our various social media platforms
respond to messages post stuff etc etc
and I try to just stick to that I make
it deliberate rather than just picking
up the phone and starting to scroll with
no particular objective and that's
really the problem when you pick up the
phone and start scrolling you're not
really looking for any particular piece
of information you're not really
determining I'm going to do ten minutes
of this the way you might say I'm
watching one episode on Netflix or
whatever the case may be so I try to
just be very deliberate and it works it
generally works pretty well if I don't
need my phone nearby like right now I
have it here because I use it to time
interviews that we do on the show and
that sort of sort of thing I keep the
phone away and if there's really an
emergency and someone actually calls me
I'll hear the phone and then I'll go
pick it up so those are sort of my
strategies and I've not found that I'm
having a major problem but I know a lot
of people I mean even over over last
weekend at the Super Bowl party I went
to there were people who were mostly
just looking at their phones and
glancing up at the game it's like this
is a this is a once a year a game I mean
yes okay it's most years for the New
England Patriots that were in the Super
Bowl fine but it's still it's a
once-a-year thing is it really is
Facebook really so interesting that
you're scrolling on Facebook rather than
watching the game so I I think I'm doing
okay big picture and I would recommend
you adopt some of those ideas as well